North Korea has fired a ballistics
missile over Northern Japan the first
time this has happened in five years
authorities in Tokyo and Seoul confirmed
the launch saying the missile flew four
thousand kilometers before falling into
the Pacific Ocean Japanese prime
minister formula kishida condemned the
ACT calling it outrageous the government
alerted residency in northeastern
regions to evacuate to shelters it also
halted some trains as a precaution
let's bring in Josh Smith journalist in
Seoul and Senior correspondent with
Reuters is this missile test more
serious than previous ones
uh certainly uh it seems like a bit of
an escalation over what we've seen so
far this year uh North Korea very rarely
launches uh any of its test missiles
over uh other countries for obvious
political reasons um or uh more
typically it fires missiles on what's
called a lofted trajectory basically
very high up into space and then coming
down quite close to the country this
time however they decided to shoot it
much further than usual
um this makes it actually the the
farthest they've ever fired missile
before and so that's obviously
concerning the countries around it you
had the reaction that you talked about
there from Japan and South Korea as well
as the United States all of them are
very concerned about this uh and the uh
escalation that this represents so what
do you think North Korea's dictator is
trying to accomplish here with this
missile test
uh analysts tell us that it has both
Technical and political uh um
implications basically they're able to
get a better uh feel for how their
missiles would react and and operate
under real world conditions but it also
sends a message we've seen uh going
drilled just this past 10 days or so
between South Korea the United States
and South Korea and this is something
that uh Japan North Korea has complained
about uh quite strongly so there seems
to be for sure a political message there
as well
there are also fears Pyongyang could
conduct a nuclear weapons test for the
first time since 2017. they say this
could happen shortly after China's
upcoming party Congress on October 16
according to South Korean and U.S
officials can you tell us more about
that
so observers uh have seen uh those
preparations complete um so they believe
that basically it's entirely up to
pyongyang's political calculations on
when and whether it wants to resume
these nuclear tests and most observers
uh think it's unlikely that they would
test particularly close to the Chinese
Congress given their close ties with
Beijing but South Korea has said that
they see uh perhaps likely window
after that Congress uh and before the
U.S elections coming up in November uh
and the the latest missile test is seen
as increasing the likelihood that North
Korea may be preparing to go ahead and
resume nuclear testing as well
Joe Smith in Seoul thank you for the
analysis